I assumed I knew nothing about her soon
should we make something up element
hundred-and-eight hassium i know
absolutely nothing about it
however the power of the periodic table
is that by looking at the periodic table
I can say well it's chemistry's got to
be a bit like iron but it won't be
exactly like iron because iron is a
light element and as the elements get
heavier going down that their chemistry
changes they tend to have a larger
number of so called oxidation states and
so what I would predict was that if
hassium was not radioactive it would
still be pretty poisonous and it might
be an interesting catalyst it would
probably react with carbon monoxide and
if it was stable it would have made a
great addition to my doctoral thesis
work